--a lot of research showing
that people learn best
when they, themselves,
become teachers
and when they work interactively
in a hands-on kind of way.
And also research showing
that people learn well
with empirical feedback.
So we designed a project
that combined all three
of those elements to
help students become more
expert at debiasing their own,
as well as others', judgments
and decisions.
We always began by having
students complete a decision
exercise.
And in this exercise,
there's usually
three people who are depicted.
And, for example, they
might be three surgeons.
And each surgeon is
described just the way
they would be on a regular
website in real life.
So you see a little
picture about this surgeon
and a description
of the surgeon.
And then the participant
or student, in this case,
has to decide which
surgeon they would
like to see, imagining that
they needed a particular kind
of surgery, like foot surgery.
Now, we, ahead of
time, have inserted
key diagnostic information into
the description of each surgeon
so that a person
reading it can tell
which surgeon is likely to
have the best success rate.
And that's what we
call in decision theory
a diagnostic or normative cue.
It's the cue we
want them to use,
it's the one that helps them
maximize their expected value.
Then we also embedded a bunch of
non-diagnostic distractor cues
that often lead people
to make biased choices.
And these are things like
what the person looks
like, their race, their
class, their ethnicity,
their religion and, really,
every judgment and decision
making bias we could
possibly load into it.
Things like order
effects, the order
in which different
information appears.
And so, what we found is that
most respondents ended up
choosing a surgeon who looked
like the American stereotype
of what a surgeon looks
like, a Caucasian male.
But, in fact, that
surgeon did not
have the best expected
value or success rate.
And so then we revealed
the data to students
and they saw for themselves that
they had fallen into this trap.
And what's nice about this
exercise is that, regardless
of what your views
are politically
about affirmative action
or no affirmative action,
everyone agrees that
there is a right way,
there is a right choice.
And that you shouldn't be
using something like race
to make the choice,
you should be using
who has the best success rate.
So that's just the
first part of the task.
Once people see
their own responses
and they see that
the class as a whole
has made a suboptimal
choice, they
feel highly motivated
to want to correct it
and to want to teach
others how to avoid it.
So that's when the real
innovation comes in.
And, essentially, what we do
is we give them the opportunity
to first, identify
all of the biases
that are embedded
within the task.
They have to name each
one and define each one.
And then they have
to design what
we call choice architecture.
It's a term borrowed by Cass
Sunstein and Richard Thaler's
book, where it's just a small
piece of information that
helps other new
respondents to make
a rational choice or a choice
that maximizes expected value.
Amazon Mechanical Turk is
this online marketplace
where you have somewhere
between probably 10 and 50,000
individuals a day who are,
in this marketplace, who
are taking surveys of
all different types.
Some of them are serving as
validation for machine learning
algorithms, others are
psychology experiments.
So ours is just one
of hundreds, if not
thousands, that are on
there that individuals
are paid to take the survey.
And that's broadly
nationally representative
with a few differences.
Students are split into teams.
Each team, after listing all
of the decision biases that are
embedded within the scenario,
work together to create a kind
of choice architecture that
will be used in a real-world
scenario-- actually
run online on MTurk--
to try to debias participants
in that activity online.
So they come up with a lot of
different ways of doing this.
Sometimes they'll include
some sort of table
to try to teach people how to
calculate an expected value
through numbers.
Sometimes they'll tell
people, don't consider
the race of a doctor,
that shouldn't matter,
or the gender of a doctor,
that shouldn't matter.
And they'll decide as a
group which method they think
will be the best way to
debias these people online.
And we'll try to coach
them through that.
What the HILT money
has enabled us to do
is systematize a whole
set of aha moments.
Because there are a number
of these moments as you
unfold the exercise
with students,
where there's the first aha,
where it's not such a good aha.
People are like, ooh,
ooh, I made a bad choice.
And then there's the, I
get to try to fix this.
And then there's
the good aha, where
they see how well
they did and then say,
oh, so this worked
better than that.
And then there's
even another aha,
which is they see
what other teams did.
And so that's really, I
would say, the third aha.
And then the last aha,
actually, it occurs to me,
they don't necessarily
see for themselves
but we try to, at a meta level,
encourage them to understand
that they can use
this kind of process
for testing their
assumptions empirically
in whatever setting they're in.
And so we use this with
executive education students as
well as Harvard
enrolled students
to help them think
about, they don't
have to just hold on to their
existing beliefs about what
creates change, but actually
submit them to empirical tests.
So we began this project
before the HILT funding
in executive education.
And we had one
scenario, we were having
participants choose a surgeon.
But we had this idea
that, this isn't just
about choosing a surgeon.
This can be about any choice
where there is a correct answer
that people aren't getting to.
And what HILT allowed us to
do and the reason we applied
was we wanted to move this
beyond executive education
to our degree program classes,
where we have undergrads,
MD's, people from the School
of Public Health, the business
school, and then test
this across a whole host
of different scenarios,
so not just surgeons.
And what HILT funding allowed
us to do was test this idea
and see how it could move
beyond just executive education,
in this one scenario, to a
whole host of different types
of students and a whole
host of different scenarios,
and really expand the
exercise and grow it.
Without the structure
that HILT brings
and the funding
that HILT brings,
we probably wouldn't
press ourselves to really
think hard about what are the
key learning mechanisms here.
And what is exportable,
what is generalizable,
what isn't, where
are the weak points?
And we also certainly would
never have had a coach to help
us have an outside
perspective on it.